all right Damien Damien where'd you grow
up where you from originally I'm from
Greece Athens Greece I was all right yes
great my dad's American my mom's Greek
my dad came to Greece met a woman stayed
out there for a long time
my childhood was home it was normal you
know a typical childhood if anyone from
Greece you know not much to do out there
like not like LA you know so it's just
pretty boring anyway they video games
all that more outside um well yes
actually um when I was younger my dad
you know I was molested I was a kid you
know by my dad you know a couple of
times actually and him being the head of
the household like it was really
confusing situation because on my mom
didn't know what to do so it went on for
a couple years and then you know finally
um you know um we just left him and we
went to live with my mom's brother for a
long time and it wasn't working out
there and I had the opportunity to come
to America well pretty much that
happened it was for a long time this has
been going on you know me I'm not I'm
not getting my into that stuff but like
it like it was just weird it's weird
everybody can't explain it but like I
thought it was abnormal in my hat I was
okay to do I didn't really I didn't feel
comfortable doing it but he was my
father and I don't want to I don't know
I just I just went along with it you
know and pretty much we separated for my
dad
and yeah and then pretty much some guy I
met a guy online and
this was a modeling person you know and
so I you know so I talked to my mom
about it he says he would plate he
wanted to take photos of myself he said
he would pay for a plane ticket out to
America to UM she pursued his modeling
career you know and anyone have anything
going on in Greece you know and there
being like a thorough clanks not the
role of it being where it is
there's not really opportunity there so
I came to America I was you know by
myself you know when I was about um it
was like 20 when I was like 22 he came
out here and you know and it wasn't what
I thought it wasn't it was a modeling
thing but it was and the funny those he
was gay porn you know there's just
gentlemen tricked me because I call mr.
choice at home I not have any family
come with me I've been doing this by
myself you know and pretty much I came
out there and telling like whoa you got
to do this for all if you know you're
gonna be homeless you won't have
anywhere to go you won't have any money
yeah I don't I don't know this place at
all you know so I ended up doing I end
up you know living with this gentleman
and doing little jobs for him here and
there you know would be a porn and
anyways he used crystal I found out a
couple months down the line and he told
me that if I use it it will help me I'll
be more motivated to do these you know
these videos than these movies and so I
did and it helped me I hoped you know
you know I always they don't like it but
all you hooked you know and after a
while I wasn't getting paid the proper
money you know I didn't finding out that
he lost some he end up doing bad himself
you know if he lost some money and he
was doing bad and he was lying to me
about payments and he was telling me
since he's living with me and paying for
my brain and everything that he should
be paying me less anyways that didn't
work out so and then coming down here
I'm not coming down here
I'm sorry while we're what I was doing
the gave point I've met a lot of people
obviously doing that you know and a lot
of them did crystal on them we're drug
addicts actually and when I left they
said I'm in because I didn't like what
was going on I end up hanging out with
these people living with these people
and that didn't last long and a lot of
them you've got here and pretty much you
know guy showed me out here and says you
know you can just get a ten you could
post up out here until you get your life
together and that's what happened pretty
much I came out here and and I've been
kind of comfy been stealing a lot of
kids and choose to get my clothes and so
I'll just say all the stuff I'm wearing
is stolen you know honestly you know and
and it's just you know it's just been
she's been bad and you know I've been
I've been trying to find a lot of jobs
out here and stuff and and it hasn't
been working out and I even went to a
couple people that I met and he said do
you have some jobs Hey
but it revolves point of you know gay
porn and I'd done a couple of those
stuff but it's not what I want to do you
know and then and that's there's pretty
much where I'm at right now you know so
it's not you're looking at Skid Row now
I live in a time right here on fifth in
town I live in arm and 8min tent with my
lady right there you know yeah
so you see you're not gay I'm not gay
better I'm having to do these these
certain things to get you know to kind
of get by for the most part you still
doing it um I haven't done it in about
two months you know I've been I've been
doing other means of getting money you
know that I'm not proud of but it's not
that you know so I'm out here I'm also
using heroin
how are you being out here you know I
Pepsi you know and and living yeah it
she's been bad you know out here it's
it's it's it's it's bad do you know it's
got people robbing you constantly left
and right you got a lot of gangs around
here you know and um and I mean being
one I'm like you know like you know hey
you know it's it's you know it's it's
weird for me you know I get treated like
a little weird let me have him dressed
and stuff but that's pretty much it and
a lot of some people found out that I
was about my videos and stuff you know
they gave me a hard time out here too
very hard times so it's been it's been
difficult you know I've been very
difficult and I'm a lady too you know
and you know she didn't know about it
for the longest time at us you've got
it's pretty much in
me I live on fifth in town I've been on
for about a night of fear about going on
two years now they are year and a half
right now and just yeah it's not it's
not and I don't know I don't know what
to do it on my life or not
yeah I'm sure this is not what you had
in mind you're coming to America it was
completely and completely I haven't told
my family back at home they think you
think I'm everything is you know I'm in
tune pictures on Google you know what I
would like my apartment to be like and
suck you know it's a data they don't
know what's going on I don't know how to
tell them that and you know yes so I
haven't talked to him in a while to
actually you know I don't want to burden
them or with that stuff so you know and
I got my lady with me and she has a kid
herself and you know and I don't know I
just you know so I'm out here living I'm
just trying to find another way another
way to live another way of moving on
them but I don't know what to do but
that's pretty much it you know times is
hard a lot of gangs they got in a couple
fights out here you know
culture [ __ ] out here they judge you
you know based on you know our living
environment and stuff and it's just it's
not the place to be you know and I just
I wish I just I would shake it you know
I wish I knew what to do I wish I had
some guidance in my life to show me no
you know just show me how to get out the
situation it's very expensive a lot live
out here in LA - very soon the pot is
preposterous ly expensive it's a
difference mainly between crystal meth
and heroin crystal my mom crystal I use
in both the same time actually I [ __ ] up
you know you know shoot them both up at
the same time first two months is the
upper heroin is it down here you know
you feel tired and numb on a heroin
crystal you feel alive and you want to
do more things the more motivated to do
things you know and crystal just gives
you a horn you - you know it makes you
feeling good anymore yeah anymore you
know kind of give raises your sexual
stimulus you know that's pretty much it
you know went up it went to down room
I do ecstasy - you know pretty much
everything well it's psychedelics - yeah
you think there's any chance of you
getting clean on your own time too far
yeah
hey jails gentle it's a good way of
getting clean for a lot of people who
just don't have the ability to do it on
their own
yeah I don't see I'm too far down my
addiction you know I don't see myself
waiting I see myself in easing to the
day I die
unfortunately you know and I I just you
know it's I'm thankful I'm still
somewhat coherent you know and you know
I just have all my teeth so I lost a lot
of teeth it looks like I may have teeth
I lost all of my back teeth to pretty
much gone I am honestly showered in a
week and a half
oh no it's just you know I get every day
every day is a gloom Bo you know and
reliving the same day over and over and
over again you know I thought it was
Jenny I thought it was before Jenner
your tenth but it's the 17th it's crazy
how days is fly past year I feel like my
life is being wasted I feel like there's
so many days are passing by that I could
do the productively and then I I'm just
adding this thought I'm just you just
going right past me you know and [ __ ]
pisses me off and and now to deal with
this [ __ ] drama and stuff and you
know I'm so new out here it's you and I
don't really know what you know I'm not
really familiar with you know have you
been us anything about about six years
I've been I've been out here and for
three years but in the US for six years
I was doing with that gentleman some
modeling for three years I was doing
horse you know so yeah
in fact it is and there's a lot of a lot
of a lot of gay people you know a lot of
them about you know I you know a lot of
people think that I am I'm into that
since I've done that you know and I kid
you don't understand it I get I get
people coming my 10 middle the night you
know I got people trying to trick me you
know and - oh yeah I got some crystal
come over here you know again in their
tent you know you pull your pants down
with but you know what brother you know
and it's just very uncomfortable me and
but I mean my addiction and and all
right it's [ __ ] up so I'm trying to
find somewhere else to go
you know so I don't deal with this but I
can't help but laugh is this is a book
of sit man and you know I'm just you
know I even contemplated suicide a
couple times you know it's you know yeah
I know it could always be worse I
understand that you know but I just feel
like I'm just I owed Eden four or five
times being out here you know you know
I'm using fentanyl now you know I've
upgraded from heroin a fin on all your
familiar fentanyl yeah yeah yeah
dangerous yeah
I owe died twice I'll say you know yeah
you know crystal does really do anything
no I [ __ ] up a whole dime in one shot
you know it's you know and it's
something good first a lot of it's cut
you know so I don't know if the focus in
that I haven't go any abscesses thank
God you know Holden I'm 28 28:27 high
polish mm-hmm
Bolivian I wish he looked in terms of
getting getting is some help some
guidance hopefully an opportunity falls
into my life nah man I because I'm just
waiting but that the whole car thing is
spinning it's gonna interrupt anything I
want to eat that's productively a
positive right you know job exactly
interfere you know so I hopefully
something happens in my life where I can
put the drugs behind me and go through
the withdrawals I move forward but I
don't see that happening honestly that's
why keeps me happy obviously you know
it's all in way of content
dad I'm content with my wife ain't happy
because in drugs you know it's it's
awful you know but um yeah man thank you
and you know I don't you know didn't I
know this is going up you know I don't
really share these experiences with
anyone I think it's a clear person that
told actually you know got my [ __ ]
about my father so you know
I feel scared to talk about it man I
appreciate you time you see me too me
too keeping it hidden sometimes gives it
more power of course you know it does
you need say you know psychologically
speaking means that you and you become
much oppressed and you become you know
it's just awful
you know so I'm just glad that I'm able
to talk about this and thank you for you
good time you know and you know Jimmy
other questions long you know don't know
I just I hear your story and it's
heartbreaking and I wish something could
happen for you I mean it sometimes it's
just jail sometimes it's just the get
you thrown in prison jail whatever yeah
it forces you to get clean and then
somehow you seem sensible enough to you
might actually yeah won't break free to
stay stay clean I never really been in
jail before so you know I'm not really
well yeah if it happens it happens you
know whatever is you know me if it
happens that way it happens that way you
know and I hear a lot of people go in
and jail on purpose you know just
together [ __ ] that
at night it's [ __ ] cold - Jesus
Christ man it's no cold Dan and okay I
need to get some blankets and that's -
[ __ ] - you and we still do [ __ ] roll out
blankets but you won't even believe this
for water this is the worst place I've
ever that's in the US you know I'm
saying and people are just [ __ ] crazy
man but it's cold but yeah so
you know I think I've been on this long
you know I think you know people usually
gone through what I've gone through
using kind of sight then psychologically
effed up in the head he know they easily
has some do usually knows I don't know
I'm glad I do I feel like I'm coherent
and I feel like that I'm all there
immensely speaking and ability I got a
grasp on him I am and I haven't lost
myself yet you know for the most part
you know and yeah actually tell crystal
is taking up you know taking effect on
me a negative way if I'm I said talk to
myself I find myself doing things that
are not normally Jenna on a daily basis
you know like like you know like the
prince is like my time I doing that I do
that a lot
I'll talk to myself and catch myself
talking to myself and I do a lot of
abnormal things and I don't see my you
know it's just I could see I can really
[ __ ] with people you know and I'm sure
my just but then again I don't see
myself stopping that no you know daddy
and daddy to make a couple times I think
three or four times I told you something
like that over three times the time
anyway
Ellen edit comment bringing back to life
yeah it's really you think some of you
go with you all that would stop you know
but I'm right here
yeah that's not it's not about a
rational decision it's about having done
the strength somehow did
steer clear of it which is which is a
lot right you know I play that everybody
means deep 99 it's crazy how many guys
off of our heroine on our heroine bag
you want to go to the guy who had who
sold in that bag because that's the good
stuff
no it's not he's they haven't seen you
know ladies but I'm that guy going today
kind no I'm saying it's it's [ __ ] up I
you're in man it's not it's not cool
it's not it's not the way you love that
I could tell you right now you know it's
not I I feel like this is a billet I'm
happy in consent but I absolutely know
that's not very correct way this is not
normal in any sense of the manner you
know I know that I understand that but
somehow I still trick myself I know you
know you know it's crazy I'd go harder
and this is normal to me you know I also
there's a coming up put the home where
am i this is this is home of me in a
sense know anything a lot of bad stuff
is happening but a lot of good stuff is
happening to a lot of acceptance a lot
of good people I came across you know a
lot of good genuine people out here too
you know but you know also you know
anywhere you going but there's any bad
but out here it's a trip down you know
you you know you hear these stories all
day but like you know but man
yeah honest a which I just say in Greece
okay pleasure you go back in time and
tell me my you know my younger self to
not make that decision even though this
shows having my father back in Greece
this is not worth it at all you know I
don't want to go to it I don't know my
family or anyone and I can I wrote
myself you know I don't know where to go
to family wise you know I can call him
and tell them to tear that it's like you
know I cry or talk that's untouched in
moments at home honestly like a year and
a half ago and I told you all these lies
or crimes I'm telling all these lies
present that's you know that's why I
imagine it's crazy you talking your
family member my mom telling you hello
life how I expected it to be but beside
me is like a rat you know trying to get
on my tank you know and it's just it
said where the things that turn yeah and
I think I got my girlfriend she's an
amazing supportive you know but then
again you know I feel like I'm the
reason she's down here you know she's a
kid needs to go pee which they can't be
with their family she's gonna be out
here with me you know I'm there I'm the
one bringing her down you know I don't
need that that you know no it was [ __ ]
up man thank you so much for sharing
your story
no problem brother thank you for your
time good luck with everything thank you
you